[Music]
all right so today the president wrapped
up his trip to England he held a joint
press conference with the British prime
minister Theresa May now the president
discussed America's special relationship
with the United Kingdom and so much more
let's take a look the relationship
between our two nations is indispensable
to the cause of liberty justice and
peace the United Kingdom and the United
States are bound together by a common
historic heritage language and heroes
the traditions of freedom sovereignty
and the true rule of law were our shared
gift to the world
they're now our priceless inheritance to
a civilization we must never cease to be
united in their defence and in their
renewal I would say I give our
relationship in terms of grade the
highest level of special so we start off
with special I would give our
relationship with the UK and now
especially after this two days with your
Prime Minister I would say the highest
level of special the president is now in
Scotland where he is scheduled to spend
the weekend and meanwhile if you thought
that the blind hatred for President
Trump was kind of unique to the far left
coastal elites in the US we'll think
again today president rums visit right
here to the UK was accompanied by waves
and waves of angry protesters by the way
as I predicted
whenever America shows strength we see
this like with Ronald Reagan and while
President Trump was holding important
meetings with the Prime Minister
thousands took to the streets yelling
and chanting and holding up their signs
and marching around and complaining
about pretty much everything from
capitalism to everything Trump but in
order to get a more accurate picture of
these protests
I actually went down to the protest
right in the middle of it interviewed
well some of these Trump hating
Europeans face-to-face take a look
why are you here today to protest like
everyone else just say it's protest
Trump I think he's a horrible person and
doesn't deserve to come to our country
it's all racist sexist misogynistic cake
what is that now why don't you like the
president it says resist what are you
resisting fascism and who's a fashion
are you max I'm a fan by the way I was
shocked at how many people knew me and
predictably as you see there was a lot
of anger not a lot of serious answers
from London's
liberal socialist freeloaders that
living in a fantasy land now stay tuned
we have the full highlights of my time
in the middle of this anti-trump
protesters coming up later in the show
but first we have new developments from
Robert Muller's witch-hunt earlier today
the Deputy Attorney General Rod
Rosenstein he announced the indictments
of 12 Russians who were accused of
hacking into former Clinton campaign
chair John Podesta Gmail's and then
leaking them on the Internet by the way
the 12 Russians charged they're all GRU
agents that's the Russian version of the
CIA by the way they'll never be in
they'll never come here for trial so
it's interesting and we've got to ask
questions about that and no Americans
rod Rosen Stein's that are suspected now
playing any role in these election
crimes let me repeat he said no
Americans were involved none now despite
this there you go over to fake news
conspiracy TV MSNBC and there's Andrea
Mitchell thinking this actually proves a
nexus between Trump and Russia two years
in and they're still believing their own
lies what's this example of fake news I
just wanna clarify it was exactly a
month later July 27th when the the
president said what he said about Russia
if you're listening and they already
were doing their fishing operations but
clearly there was a nexus between what
was happening that's
and the comments of the president
meanwhile her colleague he's no Tim
Russert Chucky Todd he's urging
President Trump to cancel all talks with
Vladimir Putin take a look it's stunning
to me that there isn't a larger chorus
here to at least postponing right why
would you if you recall President Trump
canceled canceled the North Korean
summit for a day technically based on
what he thought was you know nasty words
that were said about vice president
pence so he he threatened to cancel a
summit essentially for much less then
obviously the indict of blad Amir Putin
who clearly now at least if if you
believe the American United States
Justice Department they have confirmed
that Vladimir Putin has lied to the
president into his face and while the
left predictably is freaking out and
hyping up these indictments they seem to
be conveniently forgetting about the
time not so long ago when they couldn't
have cared less about election hacking
now remember when Trump raised concerns
about rigging the election in 2016
remember then President Obama October
2016 he just laughed at all off told
Trump stop whining there is no serious
person out there who would suggest
somehow that you could even you could
even rig America's elections in part
because they're so decentralized and the
numbers of votes involved there's no
evidence that that has happened in the
past or that there are instances in
which that will happen this time and so
I divided mr. Trump to stop whining and
go try to make his case to get votes
those serious person stop whining and by
the way credit to Jake Tapper because he
called out Obama because this all
happened on his watch he was the one of
sleep at the wheel
take a look you read this indictment and
you think boy the Obama administration
they really kind of missed the ball on
this I mean yes they issued that report
but President Obama said what did he say
he told Putin to cut it out or knock it
off it wasn't particularly strong
and then there was all this hesitation
about warning the American people for
fear of looking partisan in retrospect
doesn't it seem to you that perhaps the
Obama administration was at least to a
degree asleep at the switch now of
course that's right and we have said
over and over again on this show we have
all known about Russian efforts to
conduct election sabotage in chaos for
years let's go back to 2014 house Intel
Committee Chairman Devin newness he
warned us about all of this in the
lead-up to the 2016 election again years
before it happened Obama was president
there were countless more warnings about
this from Intel officials and many
others and excuse me
how many countries hacked Hillary
Clinton's email server was it China
Russia was at the Iranians the North
Koreans and despite the known risk
Hillary Clinton well she decided to
conduct official top-secret government
business on that private server to the
illegal which we know was hacked by at
least five foreign powers and we also
know the former Clinton campaign
chairman and the DNC they were easily
hacked today Podesta called in to CNN to
celebrate Muller's indictments we'll
tell you how stupid he is after you
watch this I think from the beginning at
the heart of this matter were crimes
that were committed against individual
citizens including myself but what's
more important crimes were committed
against the American democracy the
president likes to describe Muller's
operation as a witch-hunt
well they've caught the witches here and
I hope at some point that they will
actually be brought to justice we all
know Podesta is nothing but a political
hack and we have known about Russian
interference and attempts to create
chaos and discord in America at least
since heaven knew NASA's 2014 warning
when Obama was president and by the way
mr. Podesta though witch-hunt is not
whether or not foreign powers tried to
influence and hack into our elections
everyone knows that has been taking
place for years election after election
we know Obama tried to influence the
Israeli election to prevent the Prime
Minister our
closest ally in the Middle East
Netanyahu Prime Minister Netanyahu from
being reelected so the witch hunt is
about the phony biased political
investigation into whether or not Trump
and the Trump campaign concocted some
grand conspiracy with Vladimir Putin to
defeat your precious Hillary Clinton
nice diversion we know in reality we all
know Trump went to Wisconsin Hillary did
not we all know Americans were
connecting with Donald Trump just look
at the crowd sighs and by the way not
with the very unlikable hillary clinton
with no vision and how many reports do
we need to now show that no votes were
impacted and i can go on and on but
tonight we're asking the question why
announce these indictments today on the
eve of this meeting between the
president and radomir putin to me this
timing is suspect we all agree that
Putin is a hostile actor we all agree
Russia is a hostile regime that needs to
be held accountable but we're only days
away from the president's long scheduled
meeting with Vladimir Putin so what is
this announcement today accomplished
other than keeping Russia Russia Russia
in the headlines ahead of the
president's trip and today the president
previewed how this would play out in his
upcoming meeting let's take a look we'll
be talking to President Putin about a
number of things Ukraine will be talking
about Syria will be talking about other
parts of the Middle East I will be
talking about nuclear proliferation and
will be talking about other things I
know you'll ask Oh will we be talking
about meddling and I will absolutely
bring that up I don't think you'll have
any G I did it I did it you got me there
won't be a Perry Mason here I don't
think but you never know what happens
right but I will absolutely firmly ask
the question and hopefully we'll have a
very good relationship with the
president will be talking about it and
on Monday the show will be broadcasting
from Helsinki we'll bring you all the
details from that very important meeting
now let's turn our attention back to the
deep state after first defying a
subpoena Trump aiding FBI lawyer Lisa
Paige finally did appear before a
closed-door hearing on Capitol Hill
day now this comes after her Trump
hating former colleague and boyfriend
Peter struck testified during an
explosive public hearing in the house
yesterday last night we showed you the
countless instances where the corrupt
biased FBI investigator played the
verbal gymnastics flat-out lied during
what was contentious questioning and as
you might imagine your friends and the
left-wing destroy Trump mainstream media
we're cheering them on every step of the
way remember this is a disgraced
high-ranking government employee who
said he can smell Trump supporters at a
southern Virginia Walmart irredeemable
deplorable z' people that cling to their
God their guns their Bibles and their
religion that's I guess who we all are
what's this it was like really watching
something out of the out of the 50s out
of the McCarthy area were era where you
see someone brought up order to ask
answer questions he can't possibly
answer it was really an appalling piece
of behavior from the leadership of that
committee well I'm personally glad that
Peter struck had an opportunity to talk
publicly about this and so the American
people could see his professionalism as
well as well I think is this integrity I
think it's a remarkable that struck has
like that is actually the most robust
offense of the FBI that we've heard from
a sitting official I think that really
was remarkable it was for show it was
for show the whole thing was for show we
didn't learn a lot knew the whole set
whole thing was odious in a way the
Russian intention was to sow dissent
here in the United States from their
perspective mission accomplishment this
is a day that arguably in the minds of
many may have empowered Vladimir Putin
click shift to view today's hearing in
light of what's happened these last 36
hours President Trump did trash NATO he
shrugged off Putin's meddling in our
presidential election and now his allies
in Congress are holding what some say
looks like a show trial that's intent on
undermining the investigation into
Putin's medal one thing is for sure if
Russia intended to sow discord in this
country mission accomplished
they should be ashamed of themselves and
I do believe if if anybody watches this
they would understand that's why there
will be this blue wave because people
are just fed up with these pathetic
sniveling little
but I was not just confused who the
villain was it was very clear who the
hero was by the end of the nine hours of
pounding this yeah mission accomplished
under Obama and look what the president
said to the German Chancellor Merkel
this week when he said you ought not be
that energy dependent on Russia and by
the way we have plenty of natural
resources and energy that we'd love to
export to Germany because that
dependence undermines even the mission
of NATO do they care about government
oversight the constitution abuse of
power do these people care about corrupt
high-level actors in the FBI the answer
is pretty obvious the destroyed Trump
media's hatred for the president and his
smelly supporters it obviously
supersedes all integrity journalism is
dead there's no longer a pursuit of
truth